this is the theme the danger this is the
things is the theme shoes bismillah al
hamdulillah Salaam alaikum peace be with
you i'ma do host you are watching a Dean
show thank you for coming back for
another great episode we got dr.
Lawrence Brown it's exciting exciting
he's back with us again we had to get
someone who is well versed in
Christianity to talk about the next
topic we don't want to offend nobody we
really want the best for our brothers in
humanity some people are confused and we
want to clear the confusion and now dr.
Brown who was an atheist you can go to
the Dean show calm he has his own
private section there to hear his story
he was an atheist he was trying very
hard to be a Christian the whole
doctrine of the Trinity and many of the
other tenants of Christianity didn't
make sense and he ended up coming to
Islam Islam the same way of life of
Jesus Moses Abraham Noah that complete
and total adherence to God's laws that
complete submission and surrendered to
the One God alone and not his creation
so we come back we're going to be
clearing up the confusion about the
Trinity the Trinity is going to be given
us the top 10 reasons why the Trinity is
not valid we come back here nadeesha
don't go nowhere this is the thing the
biju
this is the phase is the thing you know
this is the thing is the thing you know
this is the angel
salam aleikum peace be with you while I
can sign up today how are you how are
you dr. Brown yeah well hamdulillah all
praise be to Allah it's a pleasure to
have you back with us here at the Dean
show and I got to just describe a little
bit about our past we have your
conversion story we've done some shows
with you in the past and you have at the
Dean show calm your own private section
so people can read a little bit more
about you get to know who you are watch
some of the other videos but in this
week's show we're going to be talking
about the Trinity you have a DD doctor
and divinity PhD in religious studies
and you're very well versed and we'll
consider you a Christian scholar so we
want to talk to the experts and there's
some lot of confusion about this Trinity
so we know that the Quran says that this
is something that Jesus are kind of the
message was never taught the consistent
message that God has always declared
throughout time that he is only one
undivided but not 3 & 1 1 & 3 just one
and we believe Jesus taught the same
teaching but there's some confusion
about the Trinity so you're going to be
giving us today the top 10 reasons why
the Trinity is not valid I don't want to
waste their time your time to just get
right to it the top 10 please begin okay
number 10 because the word Trinity is
nowhere to be found in the Bible now the
word Trinity is not as important as
finding the actual doctrine so number 9
so you just jump you just down look 10
is done when I was in the whole time 10s
done all right let's take it to nut
let's take it to number 9 10 is done you
don't find the word Trinity anywhere in
finished that was simple that was easy
okay but as I said the word is not as
important as the doctrines the question
is do we find the doctrine in the Bible
we going to nine nine number nine
HarperCollins encyclopedia of the Bible
states quote the doctrine of the Trinity
as such is not revealed in either the
Old Testament or the New Testament
HarperCollins encyclopedia of the Bible
telling us what telling us I'll say it
again quote the doctrine of the Trinity
as such is not revealed in either the
Old Testament
or the New Testament you know we almost
don't need to do the rest of this
program because that pretty much says it
right there but let's continue so we're
moving on to eight now we're going to
move quickly this is eight rows okay we
get a Duff row or two drum home yeah the
Duff let's go number eight we'll we'll
just keep moving through these the the
point then is well if the doctrine is
not revealed in the Bible where did it
come from the doctrine of the Trinity
started with tertullian in 220 siiii
what does that tell us that tells us
that the the doctrine of the Trinity was
dreamed up by tertullian who is
tertullian he was a lawyer in Carthage
around two hundred years after the
mission of Jesus Christ so this was not
a doctrine that was written into the
Bible this was a doctrine that was
derived by a lawyer and we all know how
much we trust lawyers sorry but I gotta
throw that one in because I'd love to
see what was in his fine print but the
bottom line is 200 years after the
mission of Jesus Christ that is when two
Italian came up with the concept of the
Trinity take it step number seven so we
already went from ten nine eight seven
take it away dr. Lawrence Brown seven
where did it go from there tertullian
came up with the concept in the year or
two hundred twenty siiii where did it go
from there talk to Christian scholars
they will tell you the Trinity is an
evolved doctrine meaning that it was not
a reveal the doctrine it was a doctrine
that evolved in the minds of the
theologians who developed it council of
nicea in 325 developed it further
Council of Constantinople and 381
ratified it and it became authoritative
at the Council of Chalcedon in 451 so
what are we saying we're saying over 400
years after the time of Jesus Christ was
how many years over 400 400 years out of
chalcedon was in 451 so what are we
saying we're saying that over 400 years
after the time of Jesus Christ
is when the the doctrine of the trinity
became authoritative at the council of
chalcedon that leads us to number six so
you're talking about now we went from
ten we're moving on to six and all these
things this is not something that came
with the first met Adam or the prophet
Moses and Noah this is evolving you're
taking about 400 years after Jesus left
the scene this didn't come with any of
the prophets this came from the mind of
a lawyer over 200 years after the
mission of Jesus Christ it evolved over
another 200 years after that it was
ratified into the Christian cannon at
the Council of Chalcedon 451 or excuse
me Ashley ratified at the Council of
Constantinople in 381 and then became
authoritative at the council of job all
right so we're moving on to tonight to
number what now this is number number
six number six number six take it away
please everybody knows Hanscomb the
leading theologian of the Roman Catholic
Church and he in commenting talking
about throughout the New Testament quote
there is no doctrine of one God in three
persons quote modes of being no doctrine
of a triune God a Trinity these are the
words of Hans kung okay if we don't
trust him with regard to catholic or
christian doctrine I don't know who we
can trust because he is one of the most
authoritative voices on on catholic and
christian doctrine you want to hear it
again goes like this there is no
doctrine of one God in three persons
modes of being no doctrine of triune God
a Trinity as he's talking about inside
the New Testament mine I mean it's
mind-boggling the Trinity but this is
mind blowing that you're making it so
easy to understand and all we ask is
that the people out there they have an
open heart and open mind and this you
know the truth shall set you free can we
move on to number 5 number 5
take it away Harper's Bible Dictionary
Harper's bible dictionary says quote the
formal doctrine of the Trinity the
formal doctrine of the Trinity as it was
defined by the great church councils of
the 4th and 5th centuries is not to be
found in the New Testament not to be
found not to be found the formal
doctrine of the Trinity as it was
defined by the great Church councils of
the 4th and 5th centuries is not to be
found in the New Testament and that's
number five that's Harper's Bible
Dictionary wasn't with the first man
Adam with none of the prophets and after
the Jesus left the scene four hundred
years later you mentioned some attorney
now we know how attorneys work
Tertullian yeah we're going to take a
break and we're going to come back for
number four of the top ten reasons why
the Trinity was never the teachings of
any of the prophets and it's not valid
be right back this is I don't say to
people i used to be a Christian I still
carry the values and principles of
loving Jesus Christ perhaps you may be
more than even sales Christian so I
think I got the best out of Christianity
by becoming Muslim
so many other things that you can enjoy
without drinking a sip of alcohol this
is the same thing it's not an obstacle
it's not something to cause people to
get completely desperate and start
chopping living their lives no it should
be a motivation it's only one life that
you're going to be living so you better
do it for a las channel matata I am not
afraid to stand alone if allies by my
side I am not afraid to stand alone I am
not afraid to stand alone if a las vacas
I i am not afraid to stay alone i am not
afraid to stand alone if allies but i am
not afraid to stay
back here Nadine show we
time we'd only ways nobody's time we're
given the facts not to fiction and let's
continue on with number four of the top
ten reasons why Jesus peace be upon
never taught the Trinity and his Trinity
is not valid talk to us okay we just
talked from harper's bible dictionary
let's go to number four and even more
authoritative source the new Catholic
Encyclopedia quote the formula itself
does not reflect the immediate
consciousness of the period of origins
what does that mean we're talking about
the periods of a period of origins in
other words during the time of the
mission of Jesus Christ and the
recording of the manuscripts that that
formed the foundation of the Bible and
the new Catholic Encyclopedia says quote
the formula itself referring to the
Trinity does not reflect does not
reflect the immediate consciousness of
the period of origins now you can you
can even read further elsewhere in the
new Catholic Encyclopedia it states
quote among the Apostolic fathers there
had been nothing even remotely
approaching such a mentality or
perspective nothing that's a very strong
statement for a Catholic reference work
just to make that among the Apostolic
fathers okay the ones from which through
the religion you know was passed on to
to future generations among the
Apostolic fathers there have been
nothing even remotely approaching such a
mentality or perspective that's number
four the new Catholic Encyclopedia
refuting the Christian doctrine the
Catholic doctrine of the Trinity we're
moving on to number 3 i'm going to dig
into you and i'm going to ask you some
very serious questions but i want to get
through these so we don't waste no more
time let's go into number three number
three the first commandment first
commandment not to place any partners
beside God that God is one God and that
jumps to number two I want to go quickly
we just went from three we're going to
number two wasting no time with dr.
Lawrence Brown let's code and number
too why does it jump to number two
because number two is the words of Jesus
Christ three places in the Bible Jesus
Christ as quoted as having said hear o
Israel the Lord our God the Lord is one
he doesn't he doesn't add any
modification he doesn't add any
explanation if ever there were a place
to explain the Trinity that would have
been it if you ask any Christian to
explain the essence of God they'll say
well god is one but his three he's three
and one invicta and they will try to
explain if they explained it that way
why didn't Jesus Christ why did jesus
christ say hear o Israel the Lord our
God the Lord is one period full stop
nothing more because there is nothing
more nothing more if if he had if he had
wanted to explain that would have been
the perfect spot he didn't say at once
he said it three times or at least its
recorded three times mark 1229 Matthew
2237 and Luke 1027 look them up you'll
find that he's not only saying this but
he's saying that is the greatest
commandment so that's number two now
before we go to number one people are
just going to have to wait I want to ask
you now you went from being an atheist
you didn't that means you didn't believe
in God right and you said you were
trying very very hard to be a Christian
now is it because of this and these
things this confusion here that you
weren't able to truly be a Christian
yeah and you know I think I think a lot
of people out there understand because a
lot of people they want to believe they
believe they have a core belief they
believe in God they believe in the chain
of prophethood they believed that there
were books of Revelation but they
identified and they identify the same
thing that we are talking about here
they identify inconsistencies they
identify contradictions they identify
division between what the scripture says
and what the church says about the
scripture they recognize inconsistency
between what Jesus Christ said about
himself and what other people say about
Jesus Christ they recognize that we are
you know we are defining in Islam we are
defining the problems in the Christian
canon whether that contradicts the
Christian scripture just hold up we're
gonna get to number one just just hold
on one second but if someone says you
know he didn't have the Holy Ghost in
them he wasn't full of the Spirit is
that what we miss you you mean like me
you're saying you're saying okay I can't
understand because i don't have the Holy
Spirit yeah what you got to say about
this you know I mean how can you fight
an argument like that I mean it to me it
is such a nonsensical argument why is it
nonsensical because you have all of
these people walking around claiming to
have the Holy Spirit inside them who
told them that they have the Holy Spirit
inside them a man somebody in their
congregation a priest a pastor a
minister or whatever has told them you
have the holy spirit inside you okay but
why do you trust this man for telling
you that you know is he a prophet is is
he does he have some special connection
to God that allows him to tell people
that they have the Holy Spirit inside
them you know take the evidence I
present and you weigh it for yourself
it's not going to you know it's not for
me that anybody is going to come to the
religion of truth it's for you okay I'm
not asking for your money like a
televangelist I'm not saying you know
sent send your bucks to the Dean show
calm you know i'm not i'm not asking for
your money i'm not asking for your
prayers i'm not asking what am I asking
for all right you weigh the evidence you
decide for yourself this is about this
is about your life your righteousness
you're here after that's all that's all
it comes down to you ready for number
one I'm ready for number one can we get
a duff roll go ahead number why the
reason why we should not believe in the
trinity is because when we completely
analyze the bible there is no evidence
to
port the Trinity in the first place none
whatsoever no evidence whatsoever now
that's a strong statement let me give
you some examples if you go to a
Christian and you ask them what's your
primary evidence for the existence of
the Trinity the first thing that they're
going to trot out is they're going to
say the First Epistle of John chapter 5
verses 7 through 8 where it is said for
there are three who bear witness in
heaven the father the word and the Holy
Spirit and these three are one and these
three are one okay and they will even
say it to you that way Eddie these three
are one that's how they're going to say
it well that's how they say it how did
the scholars say it the fact of the
matter is that the scholars recognize
that the First Epistle of John chapter 5
verses 7 through 8 is an insertion it
does not exist in any of the ancient
manuscripts it was written into the
margin by a scribe who in the process of
copying the manuscripts wrote it in as a
personal insertion somebody liked it
they took it from the margin they
transported it into the text you can't
do that if that's the word of God you
can't play with the Word of God then
it's not the Word of God well you can
play with the Word of God but it's not
going to take you in the right direction
I'm just saying this is what happened
yeah okay we all know people have played
with the Word of God they've taken out
things that they didn't like they've put
in things that they did like they have
manipulated it fashioned it molded it to
be what they wanted to be everybody out
there knows that there are unrighteous
people who have grabbed ahold of
religion to to take them closer to their
worldly desires okay and this is one
primary example of that the number one
evidence that people hold up as an
evidence for the Trinity is one John
first whistle of John 57 through eight
okay and scholars now recognize that
that is an insertion that was added in
that was added that's a very bold
statement now can you back up what
you're saying you said Christian
scholars have also attested to what
you're saying can you back this up sure
I mean let me just ask the people out
there you know who who is not sick of
hearing people say things about religion
and they cannot support their assertions
we're all sick of that so here comes the
interpreters Bible look up the look up
the First Epistle of John 57 through
eight they say these verses are to be
rejected dr. Schofield along with eight
doctors of divinity in his reference
Bible states that this verse has no
manuscript authority and it was inserted
professor Brooke metzker states with
regard to this passage that the words
are spurious and do not belong in the
New Testament curtain Barbara Barbara
Island bharti erman many others have
recognized that what is called the
johannine comma which means these verses
are illegitimate now is it just
individuals who recognize it no is
economic ecumenical groups of scholars
who have who have recognized it as well
how do we know that because read the New
Revised Standard Version of the Bible
read the Revised Standard Version of the
Bible the NIV the good news the new
English the Jerusalem Darby's new
American Standard Bible all of these
Bibles have removed or modified the
passage so it no longer reads these
three are one go to the most
authoritative Bibles of our time the New
Revised Standard Version of the New
International Version and you will find
that the First Epistle of John 57
through eight allegedly supporting the
proposed Trinity has been modified or
removed but let's hold it right there
and we're going to wrap it up when we
come back here in the disha I solo
indios Herrera solo ya na so classic I
would go to my room lock the door go
straight and cut thank God you know me
better than myself show me the right way
and I will not look that I will leave
behind a lot of that crater and he
creates everything it gives intelligent
to people Mohammed is one of the last
messenger since we got back here on a
Dean show with dr. Lawrence Brown were
giving you facts not fiction backed up
with evidence after evidence we were
given the top 10 reasons why Jesus peace
be upon him he didn't teach the Trinity
nor did any of the prophets and this is
not valid so we shouldn't believe in it
we shouldn't practice it and we're going
to go on and continue on your finishing
up wrapping up number one please go
ahead number one what we're talking
about is the fact that there is no
evidence in the Bible to support the
doctrine of the Trinity we've just
refuted 1 John 5 7 through 8 the next
evidence if there's any other evidence
that anybody holds up its Matthew 28
1928 19 is the verse in which the
disciples are commanded to go out and
baptized in the name of the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit what is the
problem with this verse the problem with
this verse is mark 16 15 describes the
exact same circumstance but it is the
disciples to go out and baptize in the
name of Jesus Christ so which one of
these verses are we going to take do we
recognize that there's a contradiction
between the two most certainly how do we
resolve that we look at the example of
what the disciples actually did which
was that they went out and they baptized
in the name of Jesus so we have to
either you know we have to assume that
either they didn't do as they were told
which doesn't make sense or if they were
doing as they were told the formula to
baptize in the name of the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit was was not
valid in any case even if those words
were true including those three were
three entities in one in one line does
not make them co-equal Co eternal
concept stantial moving on John 14 9
Jesus Christ is quoted as having said he
who has seen me has seen the father a
lot of people say up that's it he has
seen me has seen the father saw Jesus
Christ you've seen the father what's the
problem with that problem with that is
John 537 because on John 537 Jesus says
you have neither heard his voice at any
time or seen his form Jesus Christ is
standing in front of their faces and
telling them with his own words you have
neither heard his voice and they are
hearing his voice and he's saying you've
never neither heard his voice nor seen
his form and they're looking directly at
him okay what does that tell you if he's
saying you're hearing my voice you're
seeing my form but i'm telling you you
who haven't seen God's forming you
haven't heard his voice it's clear that
we're not talking about the same entity
some people jump in and they say John
1030 John 1030 I and the father are one
okay what happens after John 30 after
John 30 the Jews accused Jesus Christ of
making himself a god and they prepare to
stone him does Jesus Christ stand up
with the omnipotence of divine authority
and say you heard me right I said it
once and I said it i'll say it again no
he goes on to explain to him to the to
the jews that they heard him wrong and
he cites Psalm 82 6 we also know from
Psalm 82 one that we find in these
Psalms that it says that those to whom
the scripture has come the revelation
has come shall be called sons of God and
in 82 one that the judges are actually
called God's not sons of God but
actually called gods and he points out
what we have pointed out before that
this is metaphorical language and if
that doesn't convince you the last point
I and the father are one John 1030 I and
the father and one so what so what is
John 17 11 and John 17 21 where Jesus
Christ's talks about how all of the
disciples are one and how they are all
one in Jesus and God okay so it's no
longer a Trinity it's Jesus Christ the
Holy Spirit God all of the disciples all
of the believers all in one so you can't
you can't have it both ways you can't
accept this
metaphorical language as literal in one
passage and then not as literal in
another far far more credible to
recognize that you cannot accept these
passages as literal there was a lot of
information I'm sure you could expose on
this for hours and hours of you
condensed it you made it simple it's
easy to understand I feel that if
someone sincere the open hearted you
know open-minded that you know this is
going to continue to make sense and
they're going to continue their quest
and hopefully they're going to come to
the same realization that you came to
many others 1.5 billion that you know
Jesus indeed was a mighty messenger of
god you call people to the oneness of
God the same way all the other messages
did including the last a fundamental
problem how and peace be upon oh but if
those people who are out there who who
want to get more into this topic with
you and they want to question some of
the things that you have gone over with
us today how can they get a hold of you
and also maybe to read some of your
books all of my books are available
through amazon.com but the first place
to start would be my websites level
truth calm and eight scroll calm that's
where people can find you yeah level
truth 2 words level truth calm no space
in between no underscore or anything
like that aight scroll also two words
just ate and scroll calm anyone want to
have a healthy dialogue with you that's
where you're at click the contact us
button it comes directly to me thank you
okay thank you very much thank my
pleasure and there you have it those are
the top 10 reasons why Jesus peace be
upon him never taught the Trinity the
Trinity is not valid and this was not a
teaching of any of the messages of god
this is a very important time because
we're all going to die and we're going
to have to be and we're going to be
accountable in front of the one guy and
he has never ever never sanctioned
legislated any of his messengers to
teach preach anything but pure
monotheism and it's what we're calling
you to this is what islam calls you to
surrender and to submit to the One God
purely worshipping Him alone and not
what he created and it's interesting to
know before we leave
that this word Trinity is not in the
Bible but it's in the Quran the verbatim
word of god and it says don'ts it's a
Trinity you'll be better for you your
God is one God worship Him alone and not
his creation you like what we had to say
continue to come back here to the Dean
show we hope that you enjoyed this
week's show and look forward to having
you back with us again next time until
then peace be unto you I am NOT I am not
afraid to stand alone if a las bombas I
i am not afraid to stand alone i am not
afraid to stand alone if a las bombas I
i am not afraid to stand alone i am not
afraid to stand alone if allies by my
side i am not afraid to stay
you